alex taylor bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
plus de 32000 décès au royaume uni le
bilan est très lourd à votre avis le
gouvernement britannique at il été trop
lents dans la mise en place de mesures
de sécurité
il comptait sur l'immunité collective et
on voit aujourd'hui ses chiffres qui
sont extrêmement élevés oui
effectivement c'est incontestable je
crois que même le gouvernement de la hat
met lui même qui a une danse au moins
une certaine lenteur mais une confusion
sous le message je vous rappelle que
appena mois on avait une conférence de
presse où le premier ministre me même se
vanter de ces êtres enam un temps à tout
le monde dans un hôpital où dit-il
dans la conférence de presse qu'il y
avait des malades ducobu c'est un
message pour le moins floue et disais
que ce serait une mauvaise idée d'aller
dans les pubs sans pour autant les
fermer alors que d'autres pays voisins
étaient déjà en confinement donc je
crois qu'il ya eu une brouille
dans le message le premier ministre lui
même ce week end parce que quand vous
avez été hospitalisé admis dans dans un
journal san qui n'avait pas pris le
problème assez sérieusement
jusqu'au moment où il est tombé lui même
assez gravement malade donc le messager
été brouillées et les mesures ont été
prises trop tard alors justement le
début du confinement a commencé le 23
mars
si je ne me trompe pas au royaume uni
aujourd'hui
boris johnson va la panse un
déconfinement malgré ces chiffres qui
sont assez élevés est ce que on en sait
un peu plus sur son plan je sais que le
plan va être détaillée la semaine
prochaine mais est ce qu'il y à déjà
quelques petites précisions qui
commencent à paraître dans les journaux
britanniques notamment le problème c'est
que les journaux britanniques vous avez
une presse et médias britanniques sont
assez libres c'est la télé la radio sont
parmi les plus libres du monde la presse
écrite
regardez les unes aujourd'hui alors
quand un pays normal on doit été titré
sur le fait que ce chiffre dramatique
est triste que la grande bretagne à
partir d'aujourd'hui détient le record
en termes de décès pour l'europe 85 des
journaux titrent aujourd'hui sur le fait
que le virologue chef conseiller du
gouvernement à une affaire une liaison
secrète et donc a vu sa maîtresse deux
fois pendant le confinement c'est là une
de pratiquement tout après c'est en tout
cas la presse qui soutient
majoritairement par les stones sont donc
je vous dis ça parce qu'on n'en parle
pas
le message est flou si d'autres pays
comme la france notamment a fait part la
semaine dernière avec le premier
ministre des mesures que la france
compte prendre pour le déconfinement des
visions assez compliqué à expliquer mais
à rebours - la plupart des pays comme
l'allemagne la france ont essayé de deux
tonnes étaient des pistes de
déconfinement il faut qu on attendre
dimanche la ligne 1 on est l'ombre des
décès ce que à quoi va ressembler le
déconfinement britannique parce que les
mesures sont déjà un peu plus flou
pendant leur confinement
comment les britanniques réagissait à
cela justement on parle aussi de cette
application de traçage numérique pour
pour savoir voilà si nous voulons et ce
sont les porteurs du virus est ce que
les britanniques voilà réagissent plutôt
bien où est ce qu'ils sont le contraire
assez remonté contre justement la
communication du gouvernement concernant
le coronavirus c'est comme dans tout
l'été il ya des gens qui sont très
inquiet par ce flicage ambit border
délinquants leur dire on va collecter
faut donner ce qui est différent en
grande bretagne c'est que pour le moment
c'est un système centralisé c'est à dire
que les données sur votre portable sont
centralisés à l'ombre et sert bureau
central qui gère
des notifications pour dire aux gens
attention vous avez été en confort en
contact avec quelqu'un qui est peut-être
porter du vélo nice tandis que dans
d'autres pays l'allemagne par exemple
c'est un système beaucoup plus régional
il ya d'autre systèmes moustiques qui
marche uniquement par le bluetooth c'est
à dire que c'est mon téléphone qui gère
les contacts que je fais sans passer par
une agence centrale
le problème c'est qu'il ya le flou d'un
côté mais aussi de notre côté comme je
le disais il ya une presse qui très
majoritairement pour l'instant c'est
pour ça que sa cote de popularité en
dépit de tout ce que je vous ai dit le
record de mortalité pour l'europe
nadja popularité n'a jamais été aussi
élevé contrairement à d'autres leaders
en europe
allez savoir pourquoi merci beaucoup
alex taylor d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et spécialiste des questions
européennes